il nous arrive que lorsqu'on vient au
Halles ou dans des autres grandes
surfaces
on va dans les rayons on regarde par
exemple des cassettes des télés on
regarde quoi et on dit souvent
interpellé par des vigiles où on est
souvent suivi du regard et assez
méchamment on ne traite comme des chiens
on nous regarde comme ça on suit des
yeux on vient pour acheter on vient pour
regarder le prix pour revenir quoi on
vient jamais pour pour galérer quoi on
se demande si c'est vraiment si c'est du
du du racisme vestimentaire parce que
mon habillé d'une d'une façon du racisme
tout court je suis un homme de un garçon
de couleur et dès qu'il nous voit il ne
regarde méchamment qu'on a vécu une
doudoune aussi il demande si on a volé
quelque chose sur les a pas mis dans les
mains sur les amis dans les rêves ils
sont complètement tarés quoi j'ai aucune
raison de voler mais ça m'énerve qu'on
qu'on me soutient d'avoir voulu quelque
chose
je sais pas je me sens ridicule